what else is common between your
experience and some of the other people
who you're not going to name but
the ones that you personally find
credible you said that there are some
commonalities so what's another one
well um
i had an experience when i was a small
child
i can't document it my my brothers and
sisters remember this i'm telling them
at the time it happened i was telling
this happened and they said no it was a
dream but i never confused any dream
with reality or any such thing never
anything of this sort
so
it was a very real experience encounter
a single being um
that
was like a gray
i didn't call it an alien i just said it
was a little man with a bald head and
big eyes
and um
he was dressed in a black suit
and i thought that was interesting
because i found out later that uh
um betty hills
beings were dressed in black suits
it was night time where the lights off
yeah we were all sleeping
um
it was a huge house and um
in phoenix uh
cooled by evaporative coolers
so during the hottest part of the year
we would
make bed rolls lay in the hallway where
this giant cougar came down the hallway
and cooling us all off and uh
so i woke up because i felt my
legs being lifted
someone had picked up the bottom of the
blanket
and that woke me up it's not like oh i'm
dreaming an alien is coming no it was a
small man and i didn't know
what was lifting me until i looked to
see what was lifting me in
uh this little guy and i started to call
out and he dropped and ran off
when you were young you would describe
it as a little man now thinking back
is it the same type of entity that you
saw on this ship
or do you not have a great recollection
of it
i'd say it was very
similar if not the same as the people on
the ship a small man bald head very
pale chalky skin
uh huge eyes
and
dressed in black
but i i didn't call it an alien never
did i just was insisting to uh this
description to my brothers and sisters
and to this day they remember me
the only time i ever said this really
happened and they were saying it was a
dream but see that's that's one of those
stories that people are going to say oh
he's just
uh
ad living here you know
no uh
i would i i don't have
um
20 witnesses here
it's just something that i'm not
concerned with
with skeptics
i i want to know
a bit more about the commonalities we
were talking about so you just talked
about your own experience again now when
you spoke with other people who have had
similar experiences to yourself what's
similar is what i'm curious
about
is this going to get turned into
travis's endorsement of some cases and
rejection of others no you don't have to
mention any names
well it's still you know it boils down
to that eventually but uh you know
there's definitely a connection that
and a style of presentation and them
recalling what happened and describing
it
other kinds of subtle sorts of things
and i don't want to give anybody a list
of things
to to
add to their next story but
definitely
certain things that
bring a bell
and
not just in the experience itself not
just in the experience itself but
in the way
they related it to people and the way
people related to them
there seems to be a
commonality
what do you mean in the way that they
relate it is similar what do you mean
i don't want to go there come on man
i can't i can't do that to people
uh i was immersed mercilessly um
paleried and and criticized and
uh all this all this stuff uh
all that that doesn't match this this
much that and it all come back to
get the facts you don't even you didn't
even research my case you know people
are making criticisms and analyzing what
happened and they don't even know what's
been said and what actually happened
like you know
a debunker who says well travis was
never at that phone move he was always
in his mother's cabin or something
if they do their research duh
they know
that the operator listened in on the
call and notified the sheriff
he sent
people over there to
take
fingerprints
so
there's all kinds of things where all
those guys were out there hallucinating
on drugs no
a law enforcement entity
took samples from my body immediately
afterwards not one trace of any drug
whatsoever so um these kinds of it's
easy to just wipe it away with the back
your hand
seven people don't have the same
hallucination
detail
identical
um
the the idea that it was
a hallucination induced by
earthquake lights you know
the rim there is a
is
a giant fault in the ground
so the theory
that people were offering was that
earthquake lights
are what generated this blast of energy
which actually came out of me and went
right to a craft
but but anyway that went through my
brain and made me hallucinate well the
guys in the truck uh 90 feet away um
they didn't
uh they weren't touching the ground and
and how could a blast of earthquake
lights uh affect them and more
importantly why would all seven of us
imagine the same thing
people are really reaching when they
grab for these ways of trying to explain
it away
but there's
quite a variety to them and
we're serious